I think that's that's a good morning
Hank record so I remember standing on
stage with you right before the doors
open for VidCon 2011 and thinking that I
could not imagine what all those chairs
would look like with people in them and
then there were people in them hey I
want to thank you for organizing another
amazing VidCon from brief moments of
rest on VidCon beanbags to watching
charlie is so cool like play rock band
from meeting the actual Yosemite bear to
watching Philip DeFranco play ninja
nerds with me Tony D it was just awesome
I think that's not even to mention the
Gregory Brothers proving that just
because you use auto-tune doesn't mean
you gotta
I think I want to focus on just a couple
of moments first Meghan tonjes
performing on the main stage Hank you
and Alan brought Megan to dftba records
before she was on Ellen before she was
Matt famous and now her first album is
coming out and it's so beautiful and I
almost started crying listening to her
play on that couch
[Music]
haha
Oh
another moment that night people were so
psyched to hear you play at the concert
that I briefly forgot that you are a
huge nerd but then I was able to call to
mind these pictures which reminded me oh
the nerd manatee but seriously Hank
every time for the rest of my life
anyone wins about the intellectually
disengaged tastes of teenagers these
days I will play them this
Oh
[Music]
that is 3000 people singing a song about
quarks which are a fundamental
constituent of matter how can you not
feel hopeful about this world and then
Driftless Pony Club another band that
you and Alan signed to your record label
got on stage and rocked these guys have
been in a band for 10 years hated for
the first time in their lives there were
thousands of people singing the lyrics
of their songs back to them how awesome
is that ok one last moment from VidCon
George Watsky I made Watsky sign a
waiver before he did this but at the end
of one of his brilliant poems
Watsky dope headfirst into the crowd
they caught him of course because that's
the thing about the YouTube community
they always catch you later in an
interview Watsky called you his guardian
angel because you helped him out a lot
when he was first growing on YouTube and
that made me think about all the stuff
you do Hank nerdfighting
sharing music that you love through
dftba records helping youtubers planning
conferences Hank you've built a career
out of making places where people can
fall and get caught you build
communities for a living I love that I
love you happy belated Esther day I'll
see you on Monday
[Music]
yeah
that was me
Oh
and so we
yeah
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]